foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
coming up on tonight's program for a
change and money was going to clear up a
woman's mess but rishi's bow as he
enters number 10. as as you were student
stability extends to the cabinet with
the big bee stake and all the cages that
fragment Funk at Hope in the home office
sorry I was completely
they're in our studio and we've risked
them for a clue stick around for just
stop oil live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Nadine Doris and Emily
Sheffield
and I'm Nadine diary sitting in for
peers for the final time sadly alongside
Emily Sheffield while Pierce continues
to Lounge by the phone in La waiting for
his call from Rishi we're here to give
you the lowdown on our third prime
minister in seven weeks here's what he
had to say in his first speech outside
number 10 earlier today
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
trust is earned and I will earn yours
Rishi Rishi Rishi no no no the
conservative party is a broad church
it's MPS members and voters too appoint
your cabinet from across the political
Spectrum it's the only way that you can
reassure the party that you're serious
about unity and integrity and there too
was you've used a great deal over the
past few days
it's in the first act as your role as
prime minister and you will be judged on
that get it wrong and it will set the
hairs running about what type of prime
minister you'll be and what you're
likely to do before you've even begun to
talk about your policy two you have no
personal mandate to hold the position
you do no one has voted for you to be
prime minister and therefore you need to
take the 2019 Manifesto seriously it is
the only legitimacy you have and you
have to cleave to it when an election
comes you will be judged by which of its
promises the conservative party kept and
which of its objectives it achieved push
ahead with a gigabit rollout for a
hundred percent coverage it's the
biggest single driver to meet the
leveling up Target build the hospitals
get the 20 000 more police on the
streets because if you don't at the next
election people ask why they should
trust the conservative party to deliver
on a new manifest Manifesto when it
failed on the last three end the Psycho
Drama in the party sadly I think some of
the faceless and unaccountable people
inside number 10 who have been behind
much of the turbulence within the party
in recent years are still in place and
still pulling the strings behind the
scenes and I think you're a bit too
close to some of those people end it now
4. continue with the policies people
want and need such as social carry form
which cost 1 billion a mere treasury
rounding error leveling up meant a great
deal to many who are left behind in the
communities like the one I grew up in
the skills needed for our economy and
emerging Industries are creative skills
and critical thinking for our Tech
sectors they can be found in any back
street in any Community Reach Out And
show exactly what compassionate
conservatism means and five sort out our
NHS it's an Old Chestnut but we employ
far too many managers in the NHS and too
few Frontline doctors nurses and
midwives Jeremy Hunt didn't manage it in
his seven years as health secretary you
sought it out prime minister show us
What You're Made Of
wow well thanks for that Nadine we are
gonna come back to you very very soon on
that because I think there's lots of
talking points in there and we've heard
we've now got the cabinet in most of his
cabinet are in so we're going to cross
first to Westminster to Kate McCann
quality teams political editor who's
first with the latest on who's in and
out Kate any surprises in there for you
well I think they're a surprise for most
people today has been the appointment of
Sue Ella bravaman to Home Secretary but
the most recent appointments they are
still being made of course are people
like Mark Harper he's the Secretary of
State for transport we've seen Johnny
Mercer he's now the victims Minister and
Tom tugenhout reappointed as the
security minister there are still
questions about Gavin Williamson and
Andrew Mitchell both seen going into
number 10 but so far I don't know what
their jobs are we haven't seen any news
on exactly what appointments they have
been given yet but I think when you take
a look across the board which you see
next started the day by saying what he
wanted to do was create a cabinet of all
of the talents that would promote unity
and that would focus on delivering the
2019 Manifesto and if you look at the
types of people that have been appointed
some of them reappointed they are
heavyweights who've been in cabinet
before they've held big jobs before or
they are known for getting things done
for delivering people like Michael Gove
and Steve Barkley in two key offices in
Department of Health and the apartment
for leveling up and housing
reappointment of Ben Wallace at defense
and James cleverley at foreign those are
heavyweight people who have been sort of
doing those jobs for a while have a good
reputation interestingly Michael Gove
given the job of looking across all of
the government departments and agendas
to see what problems might need
unblocking so I think from those
appointments it's clear that Rishi sunak
is going to carry out what he hopes you
know to try and deliver that 2019
Manifesto but there are some
appointments that are causing a little
bit of concern I think it's fair to say
and the one so far that has got Labor's
backs up maybe that's what the Tories
want Nadine maybe you can tell me is the
appointment of Sue Ella breatherman at
Home Secretary you know she was sat she
resigned but essentially she was asked
to resign because she wrote them in a
serial code just a week ago she sent
private documents via email to somebody
who wasn't in the cabinet they needed
cabinet approval she was asked to leave
she handed in a resignation it was very
clear from that letter that she was
unhappy about it they've been around in
the background between Liz truss and her
about immigration and just a short time
after that resignation she's back in
cabinet back at home secretary and she
has some fairly strong views I think
that appointment tonight is the one that
is rustling the most feathers great
thank you Kate so much to talk about
Nadine first let's because she's just
talking about swella bravaman now this
is a this is a prime minister who came
in on his speech in his first speech to
the nation he talks about reinstating
Integrity he then reinstates swella
bravman to the home office who had just
been removed by Liz truss for breaking
the ministerial code so I just want to
get your reaction first and then I'm
going to go to the panel because I I
think for many the return of sweller
Braverman was quite a surprise yeah and
I think we're going to hear a lot about
that actually because I know a lot of my
colleagues in the concept are not
overwhelmed and
um
return or weren't overwhelmed by her
when she was in the home or selfish
before both and sorry underworld and um
I I think we're going to hear more about
that rumbling on over the next few weeks
I think that's probably a big slip up
the rest of the cabinet actually I mean
I've sat in cabinet with most of those
people it's not a lot of change it's
actually the cabinet that's been in
place the last year plus I don't know if
you remember but Boris Johnson put in
place a temporary cabinet over the
summer it's kind of a mishmash of them
both but don't you think you were saying
at the beginning in your Five Points
you've got to build a Unity cabinet I
feel that is quite a Unity cabinet that
feels like that is bringing a lot of
elements from right across the party and
there's not much change though to be
honest there's not much
people were in Michael Gove Steve
Barkley a lot of those people were in
the cabinet before now to be fair Steve
Barkley only just moved into health and
then was removed by Liz truss we've got
a new Chancellor that's that that's a
big deal
um Salma what what's your view I I feel
this is a Unity cabinet and he's made
he's made a lot of former advisors so I
think what's interesting is that yes you
can absolutely say that this is a Unity
cabinet but there are also political
realities to it so it's not just about
sort of having this broad brush and
saying I really I'm gonna it's all gonna
be rainbows and puppies and I'm gonna
bring this cabinet together it actually
is the fact that Sue Ella bravman went
out early to support Rishi and she is a
bigger head in the very powerful ERG
very messy ERG group that can cause a
lot of trouble and so I don't think
Rishi was really in a position where he
could move that and again I'd love to
hear Nadine's view on this but you know
a lot of those people like James
cleverley were big Borough supporters
and actually does wish he really want
those people on the back benches causing
trouble so I think that's also a
political move nevertheless it is
sensible to bring some stability into
cabinet it is sensible to make that as
wide as possible the challenge he's
going to have is really is everybody
equipped in this short space of time to
be able to deliver on the things that
you need to deliver Nadine you're
absolutely right in the list that you
gave at the beginning delivering on the
2019 Manifesto commitment but those
hospitals those um extra police officers
all of that is going to require real
operational delivery and this is not a
criticism of every anyone in the cabinet
but you know there are lots of people on
the back language so the conservative
party that could do a lot more with the
delivery and I think a few of these
people are a bit too new to that cabinet
I just want to bring in here because
we've got the labor advisor Richard
powersaid former labor advisor Richard
um what's your feeling on soiler Braven
because I I feel that she I I absolutely
agree with Sam with Salma immigration
was a big big thing on the doorstep in
the last election perhaps and I think
it's going to be a big thing on the on
the doorstep particularly up in that red
wall again so how's late labor doesn't
really have an answer for immigration
it's one of those ones they keep sort of
slithering around but they are it is it
is a big issue on people's doorsteps so
how are they going to counter how are
they going to counter this I look at the
uh appointment as well as rather than I
just think that looks like an act of
political weakness it looks kind of
desperate like here's somebody who is
recognized as being not simply a person
on the right but a person on the right
to you is unusually superficial in her
political School presentation unusually
insubstantial in the kinds of things
that she wants to talk about when she's
going out into the media or when she's a
Tory Party Conference there are people
on the right who are bigger hitters than
her and they and for some reason he's
gone with her in homes for Home
Secretary
in you know in the coming weeks and
months what do we think and Salma you
might might notice she backed where she
very early on
um it was this a deal was this a deal
done um
it wouldn't surprise you I'm very sorry
and I've got to I've got to say I do
agree with Richard that it's kind of you
can read it both ways is it an act of
political strength to try and unify and
stabilize or is it an acknowledgment of
political weakness and Nadine said it
again at the top you know that that idea
of one's mandate that idea of kind of
like what I can get away with and what
people will actually wear so even though
and look you know I am glad that rishi's
there it is stabilizing it is
stabilizing for the market we have saw
guilts for Dramatics so so there is a
point but we're not out of the woods
with rishi's Premiership and we have to
be really alive to that fact I do think
that there are kind of I mean I would
obviously think this but I do think
there are holes in what what labor is
presenting in terms of you know you can
be angry and upset about Sue Ella
brosman but a lot of people do recognize
that she does have a tough stance on
immigration and they are looking for a
tough stance on immigration yeah but
Samba where are they by Richard they're
not anywhere we've had very little in
the way of commentary I mean
should be out everywhere and he's
nowhere where is he
do you think right now we should be out
no not at all this is a moment well they
usually are they're usually out
criticizing the cabinet appointments
they're usually trying to fight for the
for the air time and the News waves and
they're not anywhere they're totally
silent where are they labor needs to
leave the Tories to have their polling
bounce and then in a month or two Ricky
sunak is going to get torn apart by the
conservative party that is currently
rallying around him it's going to be at
it's going to be terrible it's going to
be terrible because it's terrible for
the country because you you they surely
can't be relying on that the Tories are
looking at I mean if we if you take the
polls they are looking at electoral
Wipeout I can't help feeling a lot of
MPS are not going to want to lose their
jobs and this could we're not going to
see Unity I think that's virtually
impossible in any electoral as any any
party labor will have its own fights if
it gets to power but surely they should
be on the attack right now I think you
wait for them
waiting for the Tory party to lose
rather than labor to actively try no I
think that in the coming weeks and
months it's going to be utterly terrible
for anybody who isn't a millionaire tax
doctor in this country if you've got an
elderly relative who needs to go into
Hospital you're going to be incredibly
worried about them I'm really sorry I'm
not a millionaire tax Dodger and you
know things will be hard for people like
me as well so that that's unfair you
know
they'll be difficult for middle class
people they'll be difficult for working
they won't be difficult for Rishi sooner
the laboratory that supports the
conservative party and I'm not going to
get what's their own interests it's not
against my own interests because
ultimately we are looking at
stabilization and as much as I am
incredibly critical of the mini budget
there are trends that are occurring in
the economy that would have led to Rises
than inflation anyway the rise in
inflation was happening as the
leadership contest was unfolding in the
summer
external to the economy they are Ukraine
they are covered exactly there are no
real wage Rises so it's not a
conservative but the conservatives do
bring in a national living wage right so
there is a recognition has been a
recognition a long time ago that wages
did need to rise because inflation at
some point would go up but this is the
point that I'm trying to make is
categorizing Tories as people who just
love tax Dodgers or whatever I think is
a real false picture I'm categorizing
the Prime Minister and the people
particularly when you look at our red
wall seats so Salma do you think the
party is going to unify
I think it's going to be a really
difficult journey to Unity I I do and I
think I on the point of kind of like
where is labor I totally I think it's a
legitimate tactic to say like the
conservatives tear themselves apart I
get that but at this point and you're
quite right you know with people feeling
where they are with the electorate it's
feeling as it is and I include myself in
that I think the labor party would have
to show me and people like me that they
are really serious about this and hungry
for it and really want the win they're
not just going to fit
I still think there is a point to be
made that labor they are they are ahead
in the polls because of the Tories
failing they are not ahead in the polls
which was the case in Tony Blair's day
when they were spelling a vision out for
the country I still don't really see
that Vision so I think so I think I'm
not looking at his shadow cabbage policy
lights no wow
we're just going to say about this I'm
going to be convinced so in the coming
week weeks Kirsten is going to be saying
we need to have another windfall tax on
the energy companies that are
profiteering out of Ukraine that's how
we can pay for instance for doubling the
number of doctors that we're training
that's how we can double the number of
District nurses that we're training and
Rishi sunak is going to be saying oh
yeah sorry we're actually going to not
do that because we're okay with people
dying in ambulances outside of uh a E's
and at that point you're going to see a
really really key political difference
between labor and the Tories and that is
why already actually the polling has
been changing such that it's not just
that people are going to don't knows
from the Tories people are now saying
yeah we're going to actively support
labor that's people especially in the
red wall that is a different kind of
polling change it's going to come thank
you so much still to come on the show
he's promised to clean up the mess from
Liz trust shambolic 50 days in charge
but just how many bottles of Mr muscle
will she need to get number 10 looking
Ship Shape that's next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back well Wishy sunak has
created Liz trust's top team and
retained leading allies of Boris Johnson
in his new cabinet let's bring a former
conservative MP and Whitaker and what do
you think of the makeup of the new
cabinets
while he's obviously going for stability
that's obvious in his choice for the top
jobs bringing back Sue Ella uh who after
all has only been gone for about five
minutes keeping Jeremy Hunt uh a foreign
secretary similarly uh obviously going
for stability obviously also going for
both the right and the left of the party
to fulfill his promise of cabinet of all
the talents
um the real test now will be uh the
Parliamentary party
um because it has been ungovernable and
now the big question will be given the
breadth of the cabinet uh whether it
will now just get on with it because if
it doesn't get on with it uh kirstama
will and Anne how much hope do you hold
out for that did you think do you think
he's going to manage it do you think do
you think faced with electoral Wipeout
that there might at least be I mean I
heard other commentators saying today
they're just he'll probably be hoping to
at least get till January or February
without some big row
uh well I mean the real test will be
when the first thing goes wrong but uh
there's nothing like Prospect of being
hanged in a fortnight to concentrate the
mind uh and okay it's not a fortnight
but it is only two years to the next
general election with labor having an
unprecedented lead which I believe can
be caught actually quite soon but it
won't be cut uh if there is a continual
factionalism uh and threat and people
putting in letters and all the rest of
it Party's Just got to calm down and on
that rests everything on that rests all
the law and the prophets so to speak
everything are you happier of the
Parliamentary party are you happier
tonight than you were say last week and
what do you think what do you think will
happen the first time he drops the ball
what do you think the first big issue
will be
well I mean that that that is the big
question as to what will happen when he
he drops the first ball as he will as
all prime ministers do uh and uh in the
past the conservative parliamentary
machine was very very disciplined and it
just stood behind uh the Prime Minister
I can remember however there is a
parallel here I lived through in
Parliament the deposing of Mississauga
and I can promise you that feelings were
running very very high
Parliament Heron's not speaking to each
other absolutely Furious the whole thing
had to be settled down by John Major and
it was because there was a prospect of a
general election within a couple of
years exactly where we are now so I
believe that things may calm down for
that reason and also it's interesting
one of Major's first pronouncements was
I'm going to have a cabinet of all the
talents Rishi shunak one of his first
pronouncements is going to have a
cabinet of all the talents that will
calm a lockdown because everybody will
feel their represented somewhere in the
cabinet and can I ask you you know labor
have obviously been calling for a
general election I think they realize
that's that's not going to happen uh the
lib Dems were admitting today that they
they didn't think that was likely when
do you think he should call an election
do you think he should leave it as late
as possible to give time for the economy
time for the economy to recover because
it's not in a good place right now he's
got some really tough decisions to take
no it's not in a good place right now
nobody's economy is in a good place
right now and I don't see everybody's
economy including ours being in a good
place uh within the short space of two
years but it will be in a much better
place that's what he's got to aim for
and if everything has calmed down and we
can see where the ship is heading
um I don't know where kirst armorship is
heading because he simply doesn't have a
set of policies if we can all see where
the ship is heading I think that will
reassure the general public immensely
and I know that people are saying as
they said after the fall of Thatcher as
exactly they said then never vote
conservative again but faced with the
choice between that and the socialist
government they'll vote conservative
even if they hold their noses so on in
92 that General action that John Major
that we faced after our stick of
Margaret Thatcher the consent is only
just held on by the Skin of Their Teeth
Now can I ask you were you disappointed
at the weekend with Boris Johnson pulled
out
um I think it was inevitable for this
reason
um the Parliamentary party as I said was
ungovernable uh and if he'd come back
he'd have come back to exactly the
situation which he left and I don't
think the party uh would have been any
more stable and settled I think what
Rishi has done is stabilize the
situation
um and although I was a trust supporter
because I I liked the Bold Vision
um I know you get behind Rishi and I
hope that everybody else will do the
same because if they don't we're going
to have kirst armor
thank you so much and for joining us
this evening
in his speech outside Downing Street the
Prime Minister admitted mistakes had
been made by Liz truss and that the
government would have to take tough
decisions to restore Market confidence
joining me now is Richard Murphy
professor of accountancy practice at the
University of Sheffield
good evening hello hello
just talk us through how big are the
economic problems facing the new prime
minister we have seen the guilts uh
stabilizing they've dropped is that
going to be is that going to be a help
for him
not really let's be honest I've just got
the chart open to have a quick look at
it because I heard you mentioned that
earlier and guilts tonight are at the
level they were last at in June 2010
um they have fallen a bit today yes but
they could rise tomorrow and they might
in reaction to the budget on Monday
these things are volatile the fact is
that the volatility is still there there
is nothing that has greatly reassured
markets since quasi quatank has gone and
that definitely did help but and the
reversal of the mini budget of course
but right now we're all sitting in tent
hooks wondering what on Earth is going
to happen on Monday I've just heard
winnicum saying every prime minister
literally has their first disaster and
budgets are very often those disasters I
have a very strong feeling that Monday
is going to be a very comfortable
uncomfortable evening for him and the
newspapers might not be happy on Tuesday
morning there will be something in there
which is going to upset everyone
so Richard what do you think the Prime
Minister needs to do now to turn this
around to to study the markets to to put
the measures in place that would make
you happy what does he need to do
well the first thing he has to do is not
worry about the markets the markets will
sort themselves out the reason why the
markets will sort themselves out is that
by next February inflation will be
declining that's a simple mathematical
fact because inflation is a measure of
one year's prices compared to the
previous year's prices well by March
next year certainly we'll be comparing
March 23 prices with March 22 prices
which will have already been inflated by
Putin's War so as far as the markets are
concerned inflation will be down and
they'll be much happier prices will of
course not have fallen one iota but
there will be happiness on their part
that inflation would have fallen so
markets are easily Satisfied by simple
things like that what people in general
aren't happy about is the fact that
tonight a plate of Pastor is costing 60
more than it was only a few months ago
because of real underlying inflation
that's the disaster we've actually got
and if he's going to keep not just the
markets on side but business on side and
remember the Tories are the party of
business he's got to deliver growth the
only way he can deliver growth and yeah
that's exactly by the way what Liz trust
said but he has to do the same because
if he doesn't we are moving into a very
rapid recession and the only way he can
deliver growth because brexit isn't
going to help it export so that's just a
fact let's not discuss the politics of
it that's what we know and businesses
aren't investing because of high
interest rates and because of
uncertainty and consumers are pushed to
their limits the only thing that can now
grow our economy is increase government
spending so what he's got to do to
actually keep the markets happy is the
exact opposite of what most people are
saying which is spend more which would
deliver the leveling up agenda which I
know you're particularly keen on leading
but it would deliver the security for
people's jobs and their Futures and keep
them in their homes because if we don't
bring interest rates down millions of
people could literally end up homeless
within a year they won't be able to pay
their mortgages they won't be able to
pay their rents they won't be able to
feed their children I don't know know
how Richard sundak would deal with that
so Richard can I ask you who do you
think would be a better prime minister
for the economy but she's Dharma
oh look marginally Kia stama I'm not a
great fan of kirstama in this area
either so let's be blunt about it I'm
not playing Party politics here I'm
talking economics here
[Laughter]
I've been doing some strong labor
arguments going on this evening I can
see Salma sitting there shaking her head
why can't why would castama be better
for the economy
well look I said nothing
they have promised a 28 million billion
pound fund for investment for example in
sustainability I actually think it
should be 100 billion look hang on I
think it should be 100 billion a year
and that can be raised I don't see a
problem with raising it I would change
the rules how is that going to get
raised we just increase borrowed we just
saw Liz trust come in with all these
unfunded a unfunded tax costs but a huge
level of borrowing to fund those tax
Scouts and for that and for to help out
with people in their energy bills and
the markets reacted violently you seem
to be arguing right now
mix again talking about growth where
most economists have said there's
nothing we can do about growth for the
next two years we have to deal
let me explain why they're wrong I mean
let's go back to we have a crisis
through night was absolutely right we
have a crisis and in a crisis the only
thing a government can do is spend we're
in a crisis so bad there's probably been
nothing worse since the beginning of the
second world war thankfully we're not at
War ourselves but the downturn that we
face is so catastrophic that we need to
follow the rules of that time we
actually borrow from our own population
we encourage people to say with the
government that's where I would get the
money from to do that leveling up and
sustainability program but let's not get
frightened to the national debt let me
show you what the national debt looks
like that's it anybody who's watching
who doesn't want their share of the
national debt would they please put it
in an envelope and send it to me because
it's just money well we just saw the
cost of borrowing going makes the world
go around
they were unfunded it was unfunded it
was unfunded tax cuts and the markets
reacted and the borrowers went up do you
just want us to keep paying huge amounts
of interesting
we don't need to pay large amounts of
Interest we can tell the bank of England
to cut the interest rate we don't need
to actually increase that interest rate
by the way the way in which the
government calculates its interest costs
are really totally wrong the interest
cost is nothing high as nearly as high
as the government claims it's accounting
is wrong I mean correspondence with the
office of national statistics
Richard we're going to move our package
thank you so much you've raised lots of
yeah I I there's a lot I've got to take
it to our pack because I've seen Sama
literally shaking ahead about 10 times
so I'm going to let her have a chance to
come back on some of what you've said
Sam I just pick up because I literally
saw you going oh what is he saying I
just want to have a counterbalance I'm
not an economist and so you know I think
I think we have a better sort of
Economist in the studio who can um talk
to some of the most specific points but
I mean you just said it there what he's
talking about is trust economics and
we've just seen that massively fail he
just said the markets can look after
themselves what the markets do when
they're not happy I'm I'm like pretty uh
typical conservative right and I am I'm
probably not typical for for current
conservativism or where that is in that
I think that the state should be smaller
because I think other people in the
markets do it better now that's not
because I I think that it should be
completely free or laissez-faire it
should be properly regulated but
actually private capital and the markets
do things better than government and the
idea that government is responsible for
growth is a complete anathema to me as a
conservative I think it is about
entrepreneurs I think it's about small
and medium-sized businesses and big
businesses and do you think government
should be there to help them yes run
their businesses as they feel but I'm
also not one of these people that thinks
that it's all about cutting red tape and
it's just about deregulation I think
good regulation can deepen and
strengthen markets and sectors I just
think it's so silly to say oh we just
should tell the bank of England where
they should set their interest rates
well we can't by the way they are
independent for a reason and all
political parties at the point of that
in Independence agreed that it should be
independent and it should not be a
problem
on in his defense though there was a
Nuance to his argument and yeah that the
trust economics the big failure was that
the markets were completely unprepared
for what she was about to say can I can
I correct well on their 45p tax they
they they're abolishing that and they've
had no idea that was going to happen now
they'd already factored in the other
stuff but they had no idea about that
and there is an argument to say that
when you go out to stakeholders when you
go out to the obr the IMF and others and
you talk through with them what you're
about to do and give them the chance to
interact with that and to put their
point of view over that when you
announce a policy like you're going to
increase borrowing you don't get that
violent reaction that we got from the
markets and that was the failure of what
happened with Liz truss and her mini
budget it was the fact that it was
sprung on the markets and they had no
idea that it was sprung is that so much
of it was uncosted in
an inflationary period yeah but you have
that discussion beforehand about how
it's going to be good I think there
would have been a lot of pushback on her
mini budget anyway
I think this is not quite right guys and
just to say I'm also not an economist
but I do know but it was very nice to be
uh to pretend to be one for a few
minutes
um 89 of
um of those of that borrowing and of
those tax cuts um in the mini budget
were pre-announced 89 of it and during
that period when that had been
pre-announced guilt markets did exactly
the same thing that International
markets were doing so actually there was
a lot more space for spending or tax
cuts or not that I'm a fan of trust
anomics but there was a lot more space
for it um in the markets and I think is
generally recognized and we need to
think back we need to think back to 2010
right at that moment at that moment we
had Cameron and Osborne making a
political act excuse out of a crisis and
the result
thank you to our panel Simon Richard but
coming on next are Piers Morgan censored
is this really Public Service
broadcasting my thoughts on channel 4's
latest bit of attention seeking
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back I'm a former culture
secretary I like to say I'm a recovering
sexual estate and one of the villains in
my side of the department was culture
like this
[Music]
how do you feel about that penis
[Music]
it's gonna kill me
fever don't go out or someone stares at
you really
what's up
oh so I'm just recovering from all those
on that clip Boris Johnson's government
was that close to privatizing channel 4.
the idea being to sell it off and make
some money back for the taxpayer but the
decision is on hold while a new lot of
ministers re-examine the business case
same goes for the review Into the BBC
license fee and clips like this won't
change things we showed you this
yesterday but it's worth a replay
well this is all very exciting isn't it
hello and welcome to our look ahead to
what the papers will be bringing us
tomorrow I'm allowed to be this gleeful
well I am
so scrap the license fee and sell off
Channel 4.
joining us now is Patrick Barr wise
Emirates professor of management and
marketing at the London Business School
so you have to pay a license fee to
watch television no at the BBC no other
broadcaster I mean there's 36 billion
pounds a year if I remember rightly that
they raised from the million 3.6 you
mean 3.6 that's exactly what it meant
obviously so do you think that's fair
when other broadcasters don't get a
penny of public money uh it's not quite
true the dollar broadcasters don't get a
penny of public money because the BBC in
the UK gets most of the license fee
money it's also funds things like it
funds the the World Service outside the
UK well that's funded by the foreign
office as well and it's a mixture now
and uh s4c the Welsh Channel and so on
but about 92 percent of the license fee
money uh goes to the BBC I think the
question of whether it's fair
um I mean it works
everybody pays and everybody gets a
benefit
that might not have been true sort of in
theory but it's actually what's true in
practice so yes it works very well
but there's a numerous times let me just
finish it's with numerous times had the
question of should we replace the
license fee with another funding method
I hope we're going to have that again
we're still waiting it's a bit like
waiting for godo for this independent
review look at the alternative methods
uh if that is a genuinely independent
review which looks at the Alternatives
and comes up with good ideas it comes up
with good ideas but also tests against
the evidence then my hunch is we will
end up either with the license fee
continuing or with a universal Levy like
the German system in which every
household pays okay we will have to look
at the more commercial Alternatives one
of which is advertising and the other is
subscriptions so I think it's very good
that this uh that the government has
said this is going to happen it's not so
good that it hasn't it keeps not
happening so I'm hoping it will finally
happen so the review was ready to go
when I left um the day Boris Johnson was
out it was ready to go literally the
following day the day after it's been
done the work's done yes it just hasn't
left the department doors yet yes but
you know do you the review is because we
need to you know who will be leading it
is I I can't reveal that but you do know
but that's not but we had gone through
that process but and it will be
thoroughly independent that was one of
the the main issues was that it was
truly independent yes but you know
there's uh there are a number of issues
around that we need the debates the
debate needs to happen it's happening
Westminster it needs to happen with
people like you need to have in the
public completely agree but and also I
think one of the reasons why that debate
needs to happen is that a 75
of the 49 000 prosecutions that happen a
year for non-payment the license fee 75
of those people who are prosecuted are
women yes and you know it's a regressive
tax as you know whether you're on
benefits or a multi-millionaire you pay
for that license fee yes and I think
this now needs to be out in the open now
if you could such a funding model what
funding model would you think should
replace the BBC license because Nadine I
think to be clear I think a lot of
people became
sort of courtesy of the Boris Johnson
government that they were very anti the
BBC and there was quite a lot of
anti-bbc rhetoric and I'm not saying
yeah
but it was how it was painted we're not
saying defunds the BBC to be clear and
that's not what you're saying you want a
more fair funding so we're not saying
we're going to get rid of the BBC
because I think a lot of people get an
absolute Panic that the BBC somehow is
going to become some sort of commercial
Enterprise a lot of people really love
the BBC you love the BBC what we're
talking about is new funding models that
you would like to see fairer that it's
not a regressive tax can we be clear on
that this funding model which has been
in places that you um you remember
personality it goes back many many years
it is simply no longer fair that people
like I froze the license fee for two
years and I was culture secretary is no
longer fair that people have to continue
to pay this escalating amount there's
cost every year particularly it's not
escalating you've frozen it for two
years
okay
if I can freeze it that is a fact
if it's a fact that you froze it okay
but there are some other very pertinent
facts about what's happened since 2010
if the BBC's
real inflation-adjusted Revenue had kept
pace with J if it had kept pace with
General inflation since 2010 it would
now be over 40 percent higher than when
you froze it 30 in real terms is my
figure
yes
before but you have to Overlay you have
to Overlay that with the fact that that
the number of people subscribing to the
license fee is dropping it's not
dropping by much
I'm trying to bring some relevant facts
in the situation before you froze the
license fee okay now freezing the
license fee for two years at a time when
inflation is whatever let's say nine
percent it'll average over those two
that's another 17 cut on top of the 30
and this is in the market with growing
competition and increasing real prices
for for programs and for distribution
and Technology okay so at some point the
point by defunding the BBC the
conservative party has defunded the BBC
massively since 2010
in a market with growing costs and
growing competition
they were able to deal with this by uh
getting their overheads down by growing
commercial Revenue by making BBC for a
repeats only Channel and so on at some
point in the next three years or so the
elastic will break the director General
is going to have to announce some real
cuts at that point I don't think any of
us knows what the public backlash will
be but I can give you a clue because in
2015 the BBC did a study
focusing on BBC Skeptics the 30 percent
who then said the BBC license fee is not
good value for money okay the Cambridge
I'm being told I've got to jump in on
channel four why we've still got time in
this segment so can I say of the BBC
Skeptics 68
changed their minds once after nine days
with no BBC when that was repeated
earlier this year it was 70 percent okay
so um Richard I have to ask you about
channel four do you think we should be
proud of Patrick sorry do you think we
should be proud of programs like my
massive [ __ ] on Channel 4 did I just say
that I'm not interested in that question
why why is that a relevant so do you
think Channel 4 is value for money do
you think should be sold do you think
why don't you think it should be sold
you think that it's right that that a
publicly owned asset produces programs
like channel 40 well I think that uh
it's like the BBC as we were saying
about the review of the BBC I think it
should be given editorial Independence
I'm not a Mary White House cancel
culture person I didn't think you were
but I'm interested okay but you're sort
of saying maybe it's you think it should
be actually my my personal point on
Channel 4 is that it has a business
model which depends on one sole form of
income which is linear advertising which
is unsustainable right so now let's cut
to the chase so now you're talking what
I think is the important issue which is
every time and I think we're fourth time
run that there's been talk of
privatizing channel four that message
has been it's not sustainable and you
know Channel 4 keeps getting they've
just recorded record revenue and and
there are underlying reasons for that
but ukgi would not agree with you I
personally don't think that I think the
government has plenty on it
Patrick thank you sir I've got a cut in
because we've got we've got to keep
going with the show thank you Patrick so
much for your views thank you some of my
views yeah I'm sorry we didn't have
enough time to cover everything those
are both big topics so still to come
they're at it again isn't it about time
we stick it to these Vandals we talk to
a protester next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back another day another just
stop oil protest this morning it was the
turn of 55 tufton Street in central
London I think if it hang out of Liz
Tross actually home to right wing think
tax targeted for their work lobbying for
fossil fuel companies
so I've got a question for you at home
why would this change anything
I was just up oil protester James skeet
so James what are you hoping to achieve
by all this uh well thanks Nathan um
well as you're well aware
um our dependence on fossil fuels has
landed as in this cost of living crisis
on this climate crisis so what just to
boil uh calling for is an immediate
transition to um to renewable energy
it's nine times cheaper
um and by the way they do understand you
can't do it immediately absolutely with
a switch absolutely what we're calling
for there's no new licensing
I think that's a difference and what
we're calling for is is is
um an immediate uh roll out of
insulation of people's homes which would
help with people's bills this winter
Freeport that's not going to keep people
warm
yeah it's not going to keep babies
warming their cots
your objective and what you're trying
actually yeah
yesterday Paul came out yesterday saying
the 66 National support for direct
action to protect them
I don't know but I'll tell you what it's
sounds a lot better than that no it's a
it was a we didn't even we didn't have
to um but it sounds a lot better than
the Tory parties uh approval ratings at
them and nothing to do with us James
honestly I think you're turning people
off what you're trying to what you're
trying to achieve you're stopping kids
getting to school you're stopping
ambulances getting to hospitals
yesterday we always let ambulances
so many young people feel terrified and
they might look and think that nothing's
really changed I also would like to
point out that with a recession coming
hard down at us you are right there are
going to be
eco-climate objectives which are going
to be put to one side I I do believe
that it happened it happened
I'm saying that I I I don't agree with
it I'm saying that I sympathize with the
panic
but I I am genuinely worried that are
you happy with your message the way
you're doing it your messages
you're turning people off and you're
introducing policies the planet James
well it's got me on your program hasn't
it but I mean both of you have got
children can you honestly look at them
because you're annoying not because I
know I'm annoying but I've got I'm a man
of many times but look I know like you
can you honestly say and look in your
children's eyes when they ask you what
did you do to avert this crisis can you
honestly say that you did everything
that you could we do lots and so there's
a lot households lots of people I've
seen your voting records 18 that's not
true
I'm an absolutely massive supporter cup
26 it was the best environmental
conference
absolutely nothing yeah no James it has
to be called as Net Zero you know it's
it's put us this year was the first time
that they were discussing what the hell
are they discussing the other day
you're deflecting from the fact that
what you're doing is actually not
achieving your objective you should be
trying to bring both of you still on
side both of you are strong powerful
women you you have ended up in this
position because very admirable women
took civil resistance and and therefore
you're and changed history and you're
now in that house you see
um and and the fact is that they weren't
annoying James they were a lot more
annoying than us and they were a lot
more thank you for coming on and
fighting your cause today that's it from
me I'm off to take I'm sorry Nadine is
off to take a seat
good night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign